let's think a little bit about the
graphs of absolute value functions and
I've defined one right over here f of X
is equal to negative three times the
absolute value of X minus one plus nine
and then we've constrained its domain
this is for X being or negative four is
less than or equal to X which is less
than or equal to five
and I encourage you to pause this video
and try to and try to graph this on your
own and clearly you could graph this by
just trying out different X values and
plotting the corresponding X and f of X
values but really think about the
structure of this expression to think
about where does it hit a maximum or
minimum point and where would the vertex
of it actually be so let's look at that
just just holistically before we even
try some points so we have an absolute
value this absolute value here is
clearly going to always be non-negative
and then we're multiplying it so that
we're multiplying it by we're
multiplying it by a negative number so
this entire thing you have a negative
times a non-negative so this whole thing
is always going to be non positive non
positive the reason why I say non
positive instead of negative is that
because it could be zero so it could be
this whole like part of the expression
is either going to be zero or it is
going to be a negative number now this
is always non positive what what is the
maximum value of this function well the
maximum value happens when the absolute
value is equal to zero when the absolute
value x per at part of the expression is
equal to zero then this part is 0 and
the function hits its maximum value at f
of X is equal to 9 so when does our when
does our the absolute value part of this
expression equals 0 well let's think
about it when does the absolute value
the absolute value of x minus 1 is going
to be equal to 0 if X minus 1 is equal
to 0 if if X minus 1 is equal to 0 or if
you add 1 to both sides you get X is
equal to 1 so when x equals 1 we hit our
maximum point this whole this thing
becomes 0 which makes this whole
whole thing equals zero and so we get
the point one comma nine one comma nine
so let's graph that point and actually
let me do it
let me do it in a color that's easier to
see on a white background one comma nine
is the maximum point right over here and
in the case and that you could also view
this as the vertex of this absolute
value function so one one comma nine is
that point right over there and so we
can already guess the general shape of
this an absolute value function either
looks something like that or it looks
something like that it would look like
this if the coefficient right over here
I guess what I mean I shouldn't call it
a coefficient the thing multiplying the
absolute value was positive then it
would it be upward-opening like that but
since it is negative it is going to be
downward-opening we hit a maximum point
at the vertex in this case we're just
talking about for the reasons we just
discussed but then what happens what
happens there what happens to the right
of that vertex and what happens to the
left of this vertex well that's actually
this we don't have to do it this way
once again you could you could just try
out points if you like but I like to
really analyze what's going on here so
let's let's break up this function
definition into two pieces so let's say
that f of X is equal to we're going to
break it up into two pieces one piece to
the right of the vertex and one piece to
the left of the vertex so to the right
of the vertex that's going to be one is
less than or equal to X which is less
than or equal to five and to the left of
the vertex so this is to the right of
the vertex to the left of the vertex
that's going to be let me do this in a
different color that's going to be
negative 4 is less than or equal to X
and I'll say less than one so let's just
to be clear our whole domain our whole
domain was between negative four and
five between negative four and five was
our entire domain now I'm breaking it up
to the right of the vertex and the left
of the vertex
so this right over here is to the right
of the vertex to the right of the vertex
and this right over here is to the left
of the vertex so to the right of the
vertex for X being greater than or equal
to one this absolute value that or I one
way to think about when X is greater
than or equal to 1 X minus 1 is going to
be positive and the absolute value of a
positive thing is just going to be that
same value so for X is greater than or
equal to 1 our function is going to be
negative 3 times X minus 1 plus 9 or if
you wanted to distribute the negative 3
this would be the same thing actually
let me write it over here so that we can
write the simplified version so it would
be give myself some space so for X is
greater than greater than or equal to 1
we don't have to think about the
absolute value so it'd be negative 3
times X minus 1 plus 9 which is negative
3 X plus 3 plus 9 plus 9 or negative 3x
plus 12 so it's going to be negative 3x
plus 12 when X is greater than or equal
to 1 and the really interesting thing is
here is the slope here is negative we
have a slope of negative 3 so starting
from this point if we have a slope of
negative 3 that means every time we move
one and the increase but in the X
direction we're going to decrease by 3
in the Y direction increase by X
decrease it decreased by Y by 3 so the
slope of negative 3 so it will look it
will look like that and let me let me
actually do it in purple so that you can
actually see it that's not purple there
you go that's purple alright so it would
it would look like that and like to let
me just make it clear this is what I'm
talking about
right over here that piece of the
function is going to look like that now
what about when X is less than 1 well
when X is less than 1 X minus 1 is going
to be negative and so the absolute value
is going to be the negative of that
actual function so when X is less than 1
when
X is less than 1 let me write this when
X is less than 1 the absolute value of X
minus 1 is equal to the negative of X
minus 1 which is the same thing as 1
minus X so our function is going to be
negative so our function is going to be
negative 3 times 1 minus X plus 9 which
is the same thing same thing as this you
have to distribute the negative 3 its
negative 3 plus 3x plus 9 which is equal
to 3x plus 6 so the important thing is
3x plus 6 the important thing to realize
here is that our slope is positive 3 our
slope is positive 3 and you could even
say that we have a y-intercept here at
six so it would be this point right over
here and the line would look like this
when your slope is positive 3 you
increase X by 1 you increase Y by 3
increase increase X by 1 increase Y by 3
or another way of thinking about it if
you decrease X by 1 then you decrease Y
by 3 decrease X by 1 decrease Y by 3
decrease X by 1 decrease Y by 3 so it
would look it would look like that and
we are done we have graphed we have
graphed this absolute value equation now
the whole reason why I did that is so
that we learn it a little bit deeper but
there would have been a faster way of
doing this you could have just said hey
this is going to hit a maximum point
when X is equal to 1 because this non
positive thing is going to hit zero so
you could have said 1 comma 9 is the
vertex and then you could have just
tried out the two endpoints knowing that
between the endpoints and the vertex
you're essentially just dealing with the
lines you could have just evaluated F of
negative 4 and F of 5 you could have
figured out these endpoints and drawn
the lines but now we understand it
deeper and that's always a little bit
more exciting